ó ó
um dia todos para já não jure pela sua
vantagem porque se tiverem passar o dia
todo em pé e talvez acabem muito
cansados podem ficar sentados enquanto
eu faço minha apresentação não vão ter
que se levantar através do eu vou
encontrar e como aparece no título a
história a minha história meu percurso
na natação até agora já leva alguns anos
e por que contar as ruas que é o tipo da
apresentação porque contados hoje uma
exposição com 50 normalmente por quem
faz da atuação de confissão por quem
passa muitas horas dentro da água quem
passou muitas horas dentro da china e se
chega a uma altura que mesmo a única
solução é contagioso está no fundo então
e antes de contar a minha história como
é que tudo começou esta é uma das
imagens que o imagem sempre que estou
pra começar a treinar ea china e entrar
dentro da água e inovar não é assim tão
fácil como parece
temos que ser sempre mais forte tem que
ser sempre mais ágeis temos ser sempre
mais rápido e conseguir transpor e
depois uma frase do imepi ano em que o
antigo campeão olímpico norte americano
de natação que eu deixe que persistência
pode transformar em um fracasso uma
conquista extraordinária e é assim que
eu penso é assim que eu penso sempre que
estou pra começar a treinar tanto a
natação como também na minha vida mas
neste caso adaptado natação então e como
é que tudo começou
eu comecei a nadar quando tinha cinco
anos ou seja já quase 20 anos quantas
lojas como costuma dizer
começou tudo uma brincadeira eu fui a os
meus pais neste caso quem era muito novo
foram aconselhados a inscrever na
natação fina em conta a minha
deficiência e tendo em conta a minha
limitação e durante os primeiros anos o
hotel eu tive mais ou menos os 14/15
anos
tudo isso foi provado um crime a
brincadeira fazia prova se participava
com pia mas era sempre um vaso com o
espírito competitivo mas não é que o
espírito competitivo muita série sempre
na desportiva como costuma dizer e com
bastante descontração
até que é e alguns anos mais tarde eu
tive um primeiro momento em que
realmente pensei que
isso pudesse ser o meu futuro e que ia
ser uma história da ocupação para mim
uma situação em que eu num dos dias que
estava para começar a treinar sob um
técnico que dava aulas na piscina eu
treinava o porto modo eu sou natural e
cumbe se tem visto na área apenas uma
vez e que achava que eu tinha capacidade
para chegar mais longe para conseguir
com o pires vai conseguir ter resultados
que fossem resultado de sucesso
bushehr sincero não liguei muito aquela
conversa e no próprio dia quando entrei
dentro da água para treinar
ia pensar mas o que que eu tentava dizer
que eu estava inventado a história
aquela é só para me motivar e não
acreditava e não tinha noção as minhas
capacidades
até que há três anos mais tarde eu fui
convidado para ingressar no bairro dos
anjos daqui do leiria na equipa de
natação adaptada e a partir daí sim o
espírito competitivo do nosso maior para
o nosso mais forte os resultados
começaram a parceiro e isso foi muito
importante e os resultados começaram a
aparecer por duas razões primeiro porque
sempre me deram as condições que
incitavam em todos os atletas que
incitam para treinar e depois permitiu
também conhecer um conjunto de pessoas
que até hoje está em congrad os amigos
uns deus que estão aqui há dois meses os
dois meus colegas de equipa
atualmente eo meu treinador o teatro tem
sido fundamental e eu já fui porque a
natação é na minha opinião isso que ela
também por puro que por praticar
praticar alguns anos consigo perceber
isso eu tenho a noção que é um dos
esportes mais complicados e porque para
já tem uma dificuldade existe o fato de
ser um desporto individual ou seja ao
contrário do futebol do vasco quer paulo
quer que seja das modalidades coletivas
em nós temos uma equipa
se nós não tivermos muito cansados nós
não nos conseguimos esconder um erro
entre aspas e passar o trabalho com os
nossos colegas
estamos cansados o treino já não vai
vender já não vai ser a mesma coisa e os
resultados pois também já não são os
mais positivos e por isso eu acho que
esta frase é uma frase caracteriza muito
bem na natação
no desporto não tem troféus não tem
substituições não tem tempo de paragem e
temos apenas 'uma temos apenas uma
oportunidade para marcar gol e não
marcamos naquela altura já não vamos
conseguir marcar
daí que eu acho que o papel do treinador
é além da questão técnica da questão em
melhorar os resultados da capacidade do
próprio atleta tem também um papel
fundamental ao nível da motivação a
nível mental do atleta
eu tenho essa só fui cimento e tenha
certeza absoluta não tem problemas
linhas reafirmado se não fosse graças ao
meu treinador tem hoje há já uma
acompanhar cinco anos
os resultados não apareciam até hoje
podem pensar sim mas tu estás dentro da
água e que nada é certo é verdade mas eu
tenho certeza absoluta que saiu sem
treinar sozinho os resultados não iam
aparecer agora vamos contar uma história
que também comprova que isso nem sempre
é verdade e agora vou ter como ter outra
vez o velho por exemplo eu no ano
passado ainda não fez um ano em uma das
fases mais complicadas em termos de
treino estava realmente muito cansado e
nós sabemos que estamos cansados do
corpo não reagem da mesma maneira o
esforço enorme e tinha dores pernas
enormes e disse que a desculpa mas hoje
estou com as duas pernas e nomes não tô
consegui fazer nada direito tentou
conseguir lá e eu respondeu esquece
nesta falsa tem que pensar que adorei
atua melhor amiga eu entrei dentro logo
comecei a pensar
a dor é minha melhor amiga o fogo tem
que fechar a natação que não quer amigas
destas não é verdade e isso é mesmo
verdade
nós temos que pensar que nesta fase
quando crimes com resultados apareçam a
dor tem mesmo que ser a nossa melhor
amiga e nós temos que nos dar muito bem
com ela agora e tendo em conta também o
tema do do tempo eu acho que o outro é o
var também sempre os treinos e sempre as
provas com o espírito competitivo mas
com o rir no pensamento
eu ainda não consegui descobrir a
solução
num exercício que o mandou até pode ser
que vocês me consigam ajudar e vou
explicar qual é uma questão muito
simples eu muitas vezes já um trio de
vitto agora vai entrar dentro d'água e
vai fazer 100 metros o braço e eu penso
que há desculpa braços não consigo braço
alves braço teve que emprestar outros o
outro e eu consegui fazer esse exercício
e ainda não percebeu isso e não a dizer
100 metros braço no braço não braço
porque o outro tacho com digo agora
todos estes aspectos são recompensados e
nós conhecemos essas dificuldades todas
passamos as horas todos possamos dentro
da china quando se observa a melhor
notícia tonacci e até agora tenha
certeza que já recebi a sentença que foi
em agosto passado eu fui convocado para
representar portugal para apresentar o
nosso país quem é que o que mais me
orgulho até hoje mais um orgulho até
hoje eu subi essa notícia e posso dizer
como é lógico foi dos dias mais
importantes e mais feliz da minha vida
eu nunca mais vou esquecer quando abri
internet quando liguei o computador e
percebi que tinha sido selecionado para
representar portugal numa prova
internacional neste caso no campeonato
da europa ainda viva na holanda
os resultados foram também muitos
pedidos ao ainda conhecer 11 grupos o
extraordinário desde todos os momentos
gustavos todos os treinadores todos os
meus colegas de equipa
os resultados foram bastante exigidos e
tendo em conta aquilo que se pretendia
eu realizei duas provas em primeiro
lugar conseguir melhorar os tempos
significa que continua pedro esses
recordes nacionais só seus tempos com
meus e uma das provas atenção mesmo uma
final significa ficar classificado nos
oito melhores do da europa
amo contudo e as situações em que os
negros entre os três são também muito
grande se calhar mais do que eu tô fora
ari uns momentos nos instantes iniciais
em lei até os últimos segundos antes de
entrar dentro da água acreditem que é
realmente
muito complicado saber que temos tantas
pessoas nas bancadas as filhas têm os
câmeras de filmar a transmitir para o
mundo inteiro saber que temos os amigos
temos a família ver em casa é realmente
muito difícil
agora assim que entra dentro da água e
que tenta fazer o nosso melhor
na zaga apenas o mais rápido tentar
fazer o melhor que sabemos e temos
treinado até agora é uma sensação ótima
são momentos que eu nunca mais vou
esquecer que espero voltar aqui o filho
ainda em outras ocasiões mas que até
hoje que vão ficar para sempre na
memória
agora e pra finalizar eu gostava de
fazer um incentivo a todos a pratiquem
desporto e pratica desporto
independentemente de terem ou não alguma
limitação de terem ou não alguma
deficiência isso não é obstáculo
toda a gente consegue fazer há muitas
opções para todos os gostos como como se
costuma dizer o que eu digo sempre a
todas as pessoas é que o desporto é um
vice mas é um vício bom é o vício faz
vem então a gente devia participar e
mesmo para finalizar o xandão que nem a
brasa à minha sardinha costuma dizer eu
gostava de vos apresentar em a razão
pela qual vocês deveriam escolher todos
a natação não é principal mas é uma
daquelas que também escolheu a natação é
esta
por isso agora já sabem pelo enquanto
esta justificação tem que ser mesmo a
natação
obrigado a todos